[Musica]
ma intanto credo che nessuno di voi
voglia vederci dentro in una teca come
questa meravigliosa farfalla ma iniziamo
con qualche flash qualche flash tra
visioni realtà breve storia triste lui
un giovanotto di belle speranze lei è un
sistema operativo come quelli che adesso
abbiamo che possono tra l'altro magari
imparare e impara così bene si
innamorano ma lei impara troppo e lo
molla diventa troppo intelligente
sicuramente voi avete sentito parlare
appunto del tema delle dell'intelligenza
artificiale soprattutto di tutti questi
dispositivi che oggi fanno ormai parte
la nostra vita come per esempio alexa di
amazon piuttosto che google
il tema è che se l'intelligenza
artificiale si nutra impara un po da
quello che noi siamo il problema può
essere questo come vedete un po in
questo articolo uscito recentemente su
una rivista online futurismo in cui il
problema è che pare che questo sistema
di hr quindi di selezione personale sia
sessista
tra l'altro in questi giorni non so se
avete letto ma è stato battuto all'asta
da christie's per circa mezzo milione di
dollari il primo quadro realizzato da un
algoritmo altre visione e il sogno della
vita eterna sicuramente il tema della
mappatura di una coscienza umana
all'interno di un sistema digitale è
qualcosa che adesso si sta discutendo
sicuramente nei film la cosa si realizza
ma andiamo a vedere un po qual è la
realtà una realtà è che ci si sta
lavorando attenzione in maniera magari
un po fantasiosa adesso il progetto un
po in stand by il progetto 20 45
finanziato da un russo dmitry sco che
voleva evidentemente vuole garantirsi la
vita eterna
ma ci sono anche altri progetti come
quelli portato avanti in vari istituti
ricerca della mt stand forma anche in
italia istituti italiani tecnologia
eccetera che stanno cercando di fare in
modo di utilizzare queste tecnologie per
migliorare la nostra vita è un domani
non si sa un progetto online che terni
ma è ad esempio cosa vuol fare che si
propone si propone di raccogliere quello
che noi siamo tutti i nostri pensieri
per riuscire a garantirci appunto un
domani una sorta di alter ego eterno
altro elemento per fare questi flash
appunto tra le visioni alla fantasia ma
quello che succede episodi black mirror
nose live
il titolo originale ovvero caduta libera
un mondo in cui il voto no che i like in
più a lei che avete un po come su
facebook più potete accedere a servizi
migliori non è lontano perché in cina
stanno iniziando con il progetto legato
ai social credit system a impostare
diciamo tutta una serie di elementi a
livello sociale per cui se avete un buon
rankin un buon punteggio potete accedere
a servizi di qualità questo per dire che
oggi le tecnologie queste sono flash su
quelle che possono essere le tecnologie
di domani
sono veramente importanti e pervasiva
non dobbiamo averne paura sicuramente ma
dobbiamo gestire il cambiamento
uno dei problemi che noi viviamo è
questo il fatto che una volta le
tecnologie ci avevano un tempo in cui
riuscivamo insomma noi ad adattarci in
realtà ora le tecnologie sono più veloci
della nostra capacità di adattamento
umana e il salto tecnologico avviene in
maniera intragenerazionale io stesso
anson partita con l'oggetto nel telefono
e ora uno smartphone e magari stiamo
lavorando appunto su progetti di
intelligenza artificiale
un esempio un altro esempio molto
interessante di applicazioni positive
delle tecnologie o both è un chatbot che
è basato appunto sulla terapia cognitiva
comportamentale sono ex studenti di
stanford tutti i piedi che si sono
buttati in questo progetto ed è un
piccolo amico che ci aiuta a superare
diciamo i malumori quotidiani che ti
segue nella tua giornata ti dà dei
consigli e io lo sto sperimentando per
capire appunto un po come funziona e poi
il mondo della robotica al mondo la
robotica i robot ci aiuteranno un domani
ma non solo nei lavori pesanti questo è
boston dynamics che una società legata
al m t
quindi all'università americana ma ce ne
sono molti altri esempi e soprattutto il
tema di boston dynamics è quello di
creare robot antropomorfi e quindi robot
che sono in grado di aiutare gli uomini
avendo una sembianza anche umana
l'impiego dei robot sarà sicuramente
molto interessante in futuro proprio per
la cura e questo è un tema che va tenuto
d'occhio e l'altro tema è massei robot
un domani
saranno anche senzienti potremmo mai
trattati da schiavi
questi sono punti su cui riflettere
arriviamo un punto il punto è che in
questa dimensione di tecnologia nelle
dimensioni del digitale in cui ormai
siamo immersi come da questa frase che
ho tratto da un vecchio film degli anni
80 che blade runner e che forse anche
noi siamo il business
noi non siamo più solo nel business noi
tutti siamo il business e abbiamo
bisogno quindi di andare avanti e
cercare di interpretare quello che il
cambiamento che le tecnologie si
apportano perché questa è la parte più
importante capire come noi nella nostra
umanità possiamo riapprovare questo
percorso delle tecnologie che come
abbiamo detto poco fa sono estremamente
veloci e non riusciamo a appunto star
dietro alle cose
questo è quello che succede tutti i
giorni io questo lo chiamo il flusso di
incoscienza perché se non recuperiamo
effettivamente la nostra capacità di
governare questo processo il tema è che
ne siano assorbiti e non ne siamo
consapevoli e attori attivi non vogliamo
essere delle farfalle nella teca nella
teca di chi per esempio nella teca di
tutti i grandi giganti della tecnologia
che offrono sicuramente dei servizi
importanti ma che oltretutto hanno tutti
i nostri dati come sapete
e questo è un punto mi è piaciuto molto
e lo riporto qui il lavoro di luciano
floridi che è un filosofo in filosofo
che lavora all'università di oxford e
che ha coniato questo termine molto
interessante data object noi siamo degli
oggetti siamo un oggetto dato oggi dall
ormai dalla rivoluzione copernicana in
avanti noi non siamo più al centro un
universo e forse sempre di più ne siamo
una sorta di periferia come esseri umani
e quindi in questo nuovo ruolo abbiamo
bisogno di recuperare necessariamente
una centralità ma in maniera diversa e
questo è molto importante e quindi oggi
non solo le tecnologie sono seguiti da
technology ma sempre di più anche il
mondo delle aziende del business
cosiddetto si rivolge e ha sempre
bisogno sempre di più di figure
umanistiche quindi di filosofi di
persone che si occupino di etica di
persone che si occupano di hope occupino
di leggi e quindi di aspetti regolatori
e cose di questo tipo quindi questa è la
parte più importante quindi l'invito è
anche recuperare esattamente questa
dimensione umana fiori di parla poi
appunto del capitale semantico altra
cosa che almeno per un bel po credo le
macchine non saranno in grado di fare è
appunto questa è quella di diciamo dare
significato le cose nel modo in cui
possiamo farlo noi
quindi il nostro punto di forza è
soprattutto questo è riuscire a
mantenere questo contatto con la realtà
ecco gli elementi appunto umani legate
al digitale e avere un ruolo attivo
cosa possiamo fare quello che possiamo
fare è essere consapevoli in questo
percorso la consapevolezza ci aiuta
assolutamente a gestire non sto
demonizzando digitale e tecnologie sono
una grandissima opportunità ci
cambieranno la vita in positivo ma
dobbiamo essere protagonisti e
riprendere in mano il tema della nostra
identità digitale perché se ci sfugge di
mano sarà in mano a qualcun altro e
questo non possiamo permettercelo
quando si parla di privacy io non lo
vedo solo come un problema di tipo
regolatorio quindi quella cosa noiosa in
cui dobbiamo spuntare le caselline ma no
la privacy io la vedo in modo attivo
prendetela come un elemento vostro per
andare a definire voi cosa volete essere
nel contesto dei mondi digitali che
frequentate o in cui vivete oltre quello
reale mi auguro spirito critico è un
altro problema importante perché anche
grazie purtroppo direi le tecnologie
il problema è che sempre di più faremo
fatica a distinguere reale da un reale
il tema delle manipolazioni delle fei
che grazie anche alla intelligenza
artificiale sarà sempre più presente
sono online e quindi abbiamo bisogno
assolutamente di imparare a leggere
contesti a distaccarci ea guardare che
cosa è reale e cosa no con spirito
critico
il mio invito quindi è quello di fare
buon uso di tutte queste tecnologie ma
soprattutto cercare di essere digital
conscious grazie
[Musica]